well thank you speaker pelosi for
joining us
and congratulations for being a part of
this uh
illustrious group of women that we are
celebrating
the initiative to recognize the value
of women yes i think um i think women
over 50
uh are kind of having a moment um
there's a lot of us
and we're still we're we're we're doing
things and having
impact uh well into our 60s 70s and
80s there you are i can't think of you
in this category but nonetheless i'm in
it
and i'm proud to be in it um i'm
wondering if you could
dig deep and think about yourself and i
know you got into politics at maybe 47
um i came to congress when i was i ran
46 was
46 okay so even before that yeah
um and you had five children
when you were a younger woman did you
did you have an imagination did you
imagine your career
after 50 no i didn't i
certainly did not involve uh i had no
interest or idea that i would run for
public office
i was doing what i loved to do being a
mom
i just loved that and uh the and so
as that was coming towards shall we say
they were going away to college and the
rest
uh i i was interested in doing something
i had a lot of energy i don't know
whether i attributed to being
italian-american
or the family i was from or just a woman
just a mom who has had so much uh
shall we say uh multitasking to do
but i knew that i would be doing
something because i i
just had all this energy and uh and
motivation i i
my motivation my why to do anything
sprang from being a mom because
one my five children my husband and i
paul and i one in five
children in america lives in poverty
goes to sleep hungry at night
so that was really sort of my motivation
so maybe nancy pelosi at 25 what did you
picture yourself to be doing in your 50s
and how does that picture compare with
the reality
where you are now well after 50. you
know
i didn't really even look that that far
forward i didn't either
i think that's half the reason why we're
having these conversations
because a lot of women young women
especially don't think about their
careers after 50 60 or 70
and perhaps perhaps they should
well i think the world has changed in
terms of possibilities
for women thanks to people like you who
well as an example you as a an example
and a motivator
in so many ways but the uh i remember
thinking
when i was young that my mother should
have been
in my time because she
she could do so many things but she was
so
curtailed by her generation by my father
really even
and of course that that went by the bye
right in families now
people recognize that their daughters
their sisters their moms their wives
can do whatever they want absolutely
um so i know that your greatest
accomplishment is your
five incredible kids so putting them
aside just for a moment
um what would you consider your greatest
accomplishment
over the age of 50 well i don't think
anything compares with the affordable
care act
that was because it enabled millions of
people to have access to
quality affordable care and again for
families and for the children
and not only 20 million more but also
families to have better benefits at
lower cost more accessible
more affordable so nothing to compare to
that i consider it a pillar
social security medicare medicaid
affordable care act so you've spent some
time in the past few years
standing up to power um especially to a
president
and i'm wondering um are there ways in
which you feel
more empowered at this stage of your
life
how can i say this first of all i'm
excited to have this conversation with
you
because of what it means to other women
and to younger women
because you don't know what's coming
next
and i always say to young woman be ready
just be ready take inventory of who you
are what you have inside of you and what
you have done
give yourself a gold star for being
the unique person that you are
and so when the challenge is there
you'll be ready
and um of course little did we know that
the challenge would be such a
horrible devastation to our country but
nonetheless
i was ready you were ready and you you
stepped right up
and and that's a great message for young
women who kind of feel like oh what am i
doing
i feel like my career is stalling or i'm
not doing enough
every day of your life you're practicing
for that moment
where you may need to be ready well it's
true and i always say to people know
your why
know why you are following the career
that you are
or the pursuit that you may have in the
community whether it's education
saving the planet social and economic
justice and
and whatever it happens to be know your
why
know your what know about it so that
people will ask your opinion and respect
your judgment because you know about it
and then show people how you would get
things done
your why your what your how
and when that happens your genuine
commitment
will attract people you'll be a leader
but again don't underestimate just
you know you say it so beautifully know
your value
that that says it all i love it i
i think women that's the one key that
kind of gives them that
it does and the word that i would say if
i could give every woman
some woman something it would be
confidence
yeah just be confident in who you are
authentically you
so i'm wondering if there was a moment
in your career
after it started uh the political career
um where you might have given up or
almost gave
up and what that was no i
i didn't have a moment of of giving up
because i
my expectations were not whatever i was
doing
at the time was what i was there to do
it was valuable
it was valuable and um so that does i
hope that doesn't sound
uh over confident about things but no
one's like this is
this is what this is lessons learned
no i when i lost a race for
uh you may not re know this because i
don't know if you were born
but i lost a race for a national
chairman
it was the best thing that ever happened
to me
because i i learned so much
from what the possibilities are
i i uh do you remember when that race
was
well it was 1985 85 so you would have
been
uh was that the beginning of your
political career well no
see i have always been let me just say
sort of involved right
born into a political family i never had
any interest myself but was considered
a public service a noble calling
to help others that we had that
responsibility
so i always was volunteering in that
respect
even when my children were little they
would sing a song we got the sealers and
the
stuffers in our hands we go because they
were always stuffing
mailers as little children when i was a
volunteer in politics
only later did i run for office because
people asked me to it never occurred to
me that i would run
so in any case um uh
when i when i was doing all that i was
in my late 30s
my children were in school all day and
that enabled me
to do those things once they were in
school all day i just love
sitting here with the speaker of the
house twice
it never occurred to you to run i love
it no well that's why i
say to people to young women you don't
know what's around the corner
so just be confident in who you are
know your subject so that people respect
your judgment
uh and and that you have a plan
you have a vision and you have a plan
you will succeed so what is your message
to
women in their 20s and 30s who feel that
they're
and i was one of these women and i have
a strong message for them but what is
your message for women in their 20s and
30s
who feel that they're in a rush that
they have a lot to get done they need to
have kids they need to keep their career
on track
what do you say to those women who feel
so rushed
well my first message to them always is
be
yourself just be yourself
take stock of who you are and then
understand this
you're going to do the best you can it's
not always the best you know how
because you won't control all the
factors of it
but don't make any judgment about
yourself because
you didn't do the best you knew how but
what about to the women starting out in
their 20s and 30s who feel like they
have to get everything accomplished
now they uh again
the timing of life's timing is
is a gift that we all receive
women just have to make their decisions
decisions are the most
liberating acts you can make
you decide decide i'm going to start my
family or decide i'm going to go
start my career and then come back to
that it's hard to do both at once
but it's very possible i have four
daughters who are professionals they
had their families and their careers at
the same time
but that was their decision and don't
worry
here's i guess my simpler message would
be
your path is your path don't worry about
following somebody else's path
what it what it will have its own
natural
natural tempo and it's challenging
you know it is challenging to to
multitask
all the time with family and the rest
people tell me
that's the hardest thing for them is how
do they
allocate their time the path is long
too you don't have to do everything
right away you don't well see in my case
it was sequential
because i was in another generation for
my daughters it was
uh it was at the same time it was
and so that that was different and i
said to my kids
well now that you have children uh do
you have a healthier respect to your
mother and father for having five
children in six years and they say no we
think you're crazy
it is a lot of kids but let's just in
terms of your point
people make their own decisions about
their timing and they don't have to
comply
with somebody else's view of how that
should be
it's about what works for them
and that they are ready for what they
are doing and
that um well i won't say what i was
going to say
the one thing that somebody said to me
once my children were little
when i was living in new york actually
we lived in beekman place in new york we
have four children the oldest is four
somebody came up to me on the street and
she said i have some advice for you
get help yeah yes we all need help
especially moms for sure i
agree with that you know this is what
i'm doing she said
borrow money from a bank and get some
help
so broke sell your furniture let's get
help yeah i don't i don't disagree i
mean listen
it's uh we're balancing a lot but i love
the fact that this list really tells
young women
that there is a long runway for you and
life can interrupt your career
and your career can interrupt your life
and it's okay
it's okay and all of these interruptions
are enhancements that's right so see it
as an opportunity and it's a plus
now they asked me if i ruled the world
what one thing would i do
if i ruled the world i would
educate girls and women
in the whole world because nothing is
more important than the
full involvement of women in decision
making in our society whether it's a
governmental
education at military
corporate america or the world than to
have women
involved so a my message to young women
would be
know your power be confident
and understand that nothing is more
important than you
fulfilling your role whatever that may
be
and nothing for politics nothing is more
wholesome
than the increased participation and
leadership of women
in government and in politics so when
you're thinking about whether you should
do this or not
know that it is necessary that you do it
perfect 100 i have a few fun things here
to end up here
um do you is there an app that you can't
live without
and that is our answer okay
do you use emojis when you're texting
constantly really
what which one do you use the most well
of course i use the
eyes like surprise hearts
i have a lot to do with food food emojis
we have food emojis and i
do um uh nature
things in nature yeah but people
my family and my friends just say where
did you get that where did you get that
and i said i don't know it's just there
on my phone
but i do think that it saves time emojis
save time
they say a lot a little spirit that
comes through
and uh i like it i i love doing the
hearts i send a lot of hearts to joe
okay so what is the first place you went
to
when you were vaccinated the first place
i went to
yeah like when you were free to actually
move around again oh i haven't been any
place
okay working in any place no because the
security constrains what i can do
okay in addition to that no
i haven't found uh any uh liberation
from any of it
but it does take me to another word
women should know
that um the one thing that i want them
to know
that it is not a zero-sum game another
woman's success
is not at your expense correct we should
all have each other's backs
in numbers um okay now this is
um this is the end here i promise but i
just have
i'm going to say something and you think
of one word that comes to mind
and feel free to have fun
millennials
joy to the world oh one word that's okay
that was goodness emotion okay
um you can pick one of these uh tik tok
instagram snapchat facebook
my granddaughter oh who's 12. okay good
good good
okay let me just say bella bella bella
bella likes tik tok
um do you like being called grandma mimi
is my name
me me okay i like being grandma but
mimi is my name what's the word that
comes to mind
when i say retirement
what's that exactly
um he well i know the answers i was
gonna say heels or sneakers but we're
both in heels
um joe mika or willie
[Laughter]
depends on the hour of the the time of
the morning okay
all wonderful all wonderful we're best
together well how about
willie on sunday morning there you go
and then joe mika monday tuesday
wednesday and friday
madam speaker thank you so much i have
to say if you're asking me of a choice
me though well of course okay
no thank you say hi to joe i will thank
you